hallo freunde wir spielen heute den
traffic simulator
ich habe keine ahnung wie soll ich denn
überhaupt spieler weil ich gleich selber
wieder zwei stunden auto sitzen werde
aber na ja wort aber was ist das ich
habe vertrag die never made you from the
front
wie soll ich dann hier überhaupt nach
vorne schauen wo mache ich das denn ich
bin mit from behind
und was ist denn das der fucking ernst
von diesem spiel also ganz von vorne ich
schaue nach vorne
so und jetzt muss ich doch immer ganz
ruhig nicht auf luca alles wird gut
ich verstehe es einfach nicht sollte ich
was ist das denn ich hätte noch einmal
kurz auf die taste gedrückt und direkt
beschleunigt der visuelle kufe macht
jetzt sorgt bleib hier stehen bleibt
bestehen dafür stehen ok und jetzt
bisschen weiter vor bis meter fort
fast scheine dass mich jemand fragt was
ist so dass behinderte spiel was du hier
gespielt hast traffic simulierter 2013
bleibt stehen okay okay war ich hab hier
ans ich habe hier eine anzeige message
insert kann ich auch ins feld irgendwie
drauf klicken ist es wirklichkeit ganz
ruhig kann ich ich kann zur seite lenken
okay ganz ruhig ganz neue taktik ganz
langsam zurückfahren bis ich versuche
jetzt ganz langsam mich auf die mittlere
spur hier und dann jetzt ich bin doch
dran vorbei oder kann ich doch die
rechte spur irgendwie okay okay dpa
diese steuerung okay ich gehe auf die
rechte spur ist es möglich dass e was
ist das für ein kack ich meine ich habe
mir echt viel erhofft von einem traffic
simulator schon der ein oder andere
youtuber gemacht aber dass ich mit dass
das so ein scheiß also schaut euch die
autos an die haben sogar nicht mehr guck
doch mal die reifen von den autos an das
sind einfach nur solche papier das ganze
autos einfach nur pappe kommen immer
näher in die stadt da vornherein oder
falls das städte sind wir da
irgendwelche schilder oder whatever und
ich weiß auch gar nicht wann habe ich
dieses spiel denn überhaupt mal gewonnen
ich meine es wäre ja schön wenn stau mal
wirklich so ablaufen würde weil
normalerweise wenn man im stau steht
dass es immer so doof erst an stehst
wieder fest an beschleunigt bsb dabei
hier ist die ganze zeit dauer
geschwindigkeit
das eigentlich war schon ganz ganz
natürlich findet auch mal ein interieur
vom wagen ganz ansprechend es ist eine
sehr konstante farbgestaltung ist schon
von einem top deal antworten laut meiner
tonspur lebe ich schon in dieser welt 43
minuten und es passiert rein gar nichts
was ist das er wählt whatever aber das
ist auf jeden fall bisher die komplett
beste grafische gestaltung die ich in
diesem komplette spiel gesehen habe ich
muss lenken
ich bin komplett abgedriftet vom kurs
was in gottes namen spiele ich hier gibt
es hier noch mal ein ziel oder irgendwas
was ich erreichen muss oder so was ist
dieses spiel das kann doch nicht sein
als ob das das komplette spiel da stellt
sich einfach in diese reihe einzureihen
wir sind wieder beim grafisch
aufwendigsten elemente in dem kompletten
spiel angekommen der werbetafel way hat
die welt ja auch mal ein ende was ist
das für ein spiel gefällt euch möchte
dir mehr von solchen die story mit
leicht leid dass ich jetzt heute so was
auf dem kanal bringe ich dachte echt es
hätte mehr elemente und man könnte mehr
machen
hut ab das war die aufforderung ist dass
ich das jetzt in echt tun soll in echt
den staub aha bäume wenn es euch
gefallen hat was es glaube ich nicht
getan hat freude dieses spiel hat mich
ziemlich müde über